hello everyone and welcome to Round
seven of the 2018 LT box Norway
championship we have a very nice game
between my Simba Sheila Grove and the
Vishwanathan Anand now ever since
Dingley ran left the tournament every
round there is one player who does not
have an opponent in round seven that was
Magnus Carlsen but before we check out
the game considering the the photo
challenge from the last video yes of
course it was Paul Morphy and of course
it was the Opera House game or a Night
at the Opera there are more more names
to this game so for this for this video
we also have a nice photo challenge so
here it is try to guess who it is
and let's see it so here it is
it's another photo of the greatest
quality but just what a one glimpse at
that sweater should immediately tell you
who that is so good luck in the comment
section so getting back to this one
before we actually see the game we do
have some very interesting news as
before round seven there was a rest day
so the players were taken on a yacht
trip so here we have it either have it
players are getting ready to board the
actors on the Maxime kurakin in the back
Wesley Soudan clearin and shaktimaan
Musharraf and a suspiciously happy
person standing behind them and another
photo I hope you're ready for this one
as this this photo is pure joy so let's
see it here it is this is this is one
nice photo here you can see all of them
enjoying themselves Dingley were and
appears to be appears to be conversing
with someone someone who didn't fit in
the photo and none of the players are
actually ready for for a trip with a yak
you know they are not too dressed
accordingly only the Frenchman Maxime
were Sheila Grove
you know rocking those shorts and one
one player who appears to be you know
extremely happy is shocked their mother
Yara of Kirkland is not very impressed
as you know he's been on iocked plenty
of times but mama dro definitely looks
like someone who should have been in a
video of Lonely Island's I'm on a boat
so let's see this game here okay I
I'd prepared that for the standings but
let me just add one more sorry about
that
forgot to add this one okay here it is
sorry about that okay there we have it a
game from a photo from this round
very nice okay
now that now that we have that let's
check out the game so it's a it's an
extremely theoretical gaming and the
this line was played so many times and
at the a lot of games were played in
this exact line a line until moved 17
only until after move 17 it's a new game
that's actually being played between
Maxime and Vishwanathan Anand now are
both players aware of this it's not not
really certain but to some degree I
believe I believe they they of course
are so let's see it we have efore e5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
b5 serve that Bishop to b5 de royal opus
a6 attacking the bishop bishop to a4 and
Knight to f6
so the Murphy's defense is on the board
as a6 was played we have castles and now
Knight captures on e4 all pretty
standard d4 we have b5 Bishop to b3 and
d5 now D captures 95 Bishop to e6 and
now C 3 we have Bishop to e7 9 b d2
castles and rook to e1
nice to see 5 would an attack on the
bishop on b3 and first night the d4 we
have Knight captures pawn captures
attacking the knight and now you could
capture the bishop although it's a it's
not really it's not really the greatest
idea a much stronger move is night to d3
which was a test that already by a lot
of players and even after rook to e3
which was played by Maxime this position
was on the board by you know a lot of
players had this position on the board
one one of the more famous games is
Alexei sure of versus magnus carlsen
where magnus carlsen played a night cap
Chauncy one I was played in 2007 in
Moscow Intel's memorial and while night
captures on c1 is the strongest move
recommended by the engine and Maxine was
actually expecting diamonds to play this
alexei sure won that game against magnus
carlsen so maybe i don't know if this is
something Anand was aware of but Anand
avoids the night captors and c1 and he
goes Knight to f4 and this was already a
surprise to Maxine and here he wasn't
really sure what to do he said he didn't
like rook to c3 immediately before his
coming there's really really no good
good Square for the rookie he thought it
worked the c6 was a bit too adventurous
so he played Knight to f3 he simply
couldn't find a you know another idea we
have Bishop to g4 by Anand h3 Bishop to
h5 and now comes Rock to c3 and it's
only after this move rook to c3 that a
completely new game is being played
before
rook the c3 I found I found another game
with Queen to c2 already been played but
after up the c3 now it's a completely
new game so this opens up an attack from
the bishop to the night on and retreats
at night 3 6
we have g4 attacking the bishop bishop
to g6 and now Bishop to e3 developing
your bishop of course rook to c1 is
coming the double rooks on the C file
and a5 by Ireland bush of the c2
offering a trade of bishops and now
Bishop to b4 attacking the rook rook to
b3 and here comes f5 f5 is a very nice
idea which maxime as he said in an
interview was definitely not expecting
and he couldn't really find a nice a
nice way to deal with this he thought
okay if I go a3 then Bishop to e7
I haven't really accomplished anything I
only you know strengthened blacks the
grip on the g5 square black will be able
to exchange pieces here and bring his
Queen over to the King side to attack
and because of h3 and g5 were played a
h3 and G forward were played the white
king is feeling the draft
so after this f-5e captures on f6 on
poisson we have Bishop captures on c2
Queen captures on c2
and now Queen captures on e6 Knight to
e5 and now comes an ins idea Anand said
that he he definitely wanted to
sacrifice the exchange here either by
going Bishop to d6 but then he decided
not to go for Bishop to d6 rather he
played c5 and okay we have Knight to d7
this is a fork forking the Queen and the
rook Queen to f7 and now there's really
no no better move
we have Knight captures on f8 rook
captures and white is up the exchange
but it's very hard to do something
useful with the rooks this rock isn't
doing anything and it doesn't really
matter where you develop it it will
still be doing well pretty much nothing
and this rook is completely useless so
there's this really little little you
can do here if you attack the bishop
simply c4 you will either free the
bishop or now you will either win the
exchange back so there's a really no
good way to keep the exchange and I move
like rook to d3 if you if you try to
even keep the exchange by you know
someone who works like rule d3 Rudy one
then you will not have a lot of fun
c4 would come immediately making room
for the bishop and if you again try to
save the rook then Queen to f3 and white
is still up the exchange but black is so
active that white doesn't doesn't have a
good move after something like a3 Bishop
is coming to d6 all of all of the blacks
pieces are coming towards the black King
look if one h5 is coming now this will
break open the Kings side G captures now
look to a5 even that and white white
still doesn't have a good move black was
simply checkmate the the White King
Bishop h2 check a little Bishop
sacrifice just to show off rook captures
on h5 and there's really no with defense
against Queen to h3 whatever you play
will it will lose you the game so a very
delicate position and a very nice
exchange sacrificed by Anand
so Queen to f5 immediately Trading
Queens but again this you have to give
the exchange back so we have pawn
captures on d4 Queen captures on f7 rook
captures on f7 and now here
actors on before this is the move that
wasn't the most precise and it allowed
to go for something more than a draw
with the black pieces a move that was a
bit better but it's I don't think it
would be possible to find this over the
board is a three actually it seems
completely the same but now after night
the cc5 you do want to win back the
exchange only now do you play roof
capture some before and now after a
capture some before you have Bishop
captures than before this is the very
important move Knight to e6 attacking
the bishop Bishop to e5 now getting out
of the way and after night at 4:00
attacking the h3 porn Bishop captures
rook captures now a4 with characters
captures and it would seem that the
material on the board is equal and it's
a it's a drawn drawn position the only
difference is between a three and only
then capturing the bishop and what
Maxime played that is rook captures
Bishop immediately is now that after a
capture some v4 and Bishop this Bishop
can no longer grab the d4 pawn which was
a very important factor now the knight
is an e6 defending it instead of on c5
so okay brush up to d2 and d3 now now
Anand uses his extra pawn to mess up a
mess of White's pawn structure pushing
the pawn doesn't doesn't really do all
that much for white either so pawn
captures some b3 and now rook to f3 the
material the material is equal now but
black is much more active and a knight
will prove to be more useful than Bishop
here we have B for now rook to d3
attacking the bishop
we have rook to e1 and King to f7 attack
defending the knight on e6 Bishop to c1
and now rook captures on h3 r up to the
rook to e5 attacking the d5 phone and it
seems like the only way to defend the
pawn would be nice the c7 but Allen
finds another way rook to d3 now
capturing the point is it's impossible
do to rook to d1 check winning the
bishop so King to f1 now rook to d1
check will be met with rook to e1
rook to d1 now and wants the force the
trade of rooks s he is up upon and he
wants to push this all the way to a win
rook e1 we have rook captures King
captures and g6 now pawn to f4
we had 98 and g5 now here honestly King
to e6 both players have made their 40th
move time control has been reached and
it was in this position after King b6
that Maxim for Sheila Grove resigned the
game and a first victory for Viswanathan
Anand former world champion in this
tournament in round 7 and it's very
interesting this is the first win in
this tournament that happened with the
black pieces one of the interesting
questions I saw in an interview with on
and after the game on a rule of asked
him if you know if he was expecting to
catch up to Magnus cos and Wesley so in
the lead because now okay I we do have
the standings but they're not the most
precise standing says you see a
vishwanatham Island is now first with
four out of seven but Wesley so is
second with three and a half out of six
as you can see Carlson also has three
and a half out of six so basically
Island so and cousin are currently in
the lead you know all tied because
because after Dingley ran left a left
the tournament it's now some of them
have seven games some of him six games
but you know all in all i will try to
find a nicer table you know a nicer
table of standings tomorrow so we will
be able to enjoy that as well but yeah
you know the important thing is that you
know that currently after around 700 so
and cause and are in the lead and yeah I
know Erin wasn't like say he said that
he didn't really expect this but you
know it's every game you play an
extremely tough opponent and you know it
was at this moment when rook after some
before was played you know if he came
you know the game probably ends in a
draw but after rook before you know it
came as a surprise but it resulted in
the first victory with the black pieces
in the tournament so you know it's chess
anything can happen
and so it did so yeah a very nice game
by vishwanatham I'm the very nice
exchanged sacrifice which you know there
was no way to actually keep the exchange
sacrifice but still you know he was only
deciding on how to how to sacrifice the
exchange either we are c5 or Bishop to
d6 so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Slobodan under cottage and Roberts
Robert Jones
Samuel druggers and the manhole Musa for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here I
think y'all for watching and I will see
you soon with another game and maybe
some of the game from the suggestions I
will see if I will have time but
definitely with the game from around 8
of the 2018 all t-box Norway
championship thank you and I'll see you
soon